-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Paula Pell,
one of the stars of "Girls5eva."
You actually encountered
somebody
who had road rage towards you.
-Yes, I had something happen out
in Los Angeles a few years ago,
where I was on Sepulveda, and if
you've never been to L.A.,
it's, you know, a lot --
[ Light applause ]
Someone's like, "Sepulveda!"
[ Laughter ]
It's along the main highway,
but it's like another side road,
sort of a frontage road,
as they would say.
But it has a lot of lights.
And so, you know, if the traffic
is in complete hell --
Friday-afternoon hell,
you're never going anywhere.
You're just waiting for the next
light, and then you scoot up
like seven feet and then you
scoot up seven feet.
So it takes forever and ever,
and you age many years
in the car in L.A.
And so I was in the car,
going home,
perfectly good mood on a Friday.
And I'm driving, and I look back
in my rearview mirror,
and this guy is losing his mind,
screaming at who I thought was
driving next to him, and he had
this red brand-new Cadillac.
He had, you know, a suit on.
Very, you know, cleaned-up.
And he was just losing his mind.
I'm like, "Ooh, this is
something fun to watch.
You know, it's a good television
show to watch."
And so I'm, like, kind of
checking out, laughing about it.
And then I see him peel up next
to me, and he's screaming at me.
He's screaming at me
through the closed window.
And so I finally was
just like...
I did my window and I said,
"What's your issue?
What's your problem?"
And he said -- Get ready, guys.
There aren't kids here, right?
He said, "Say one more word,
you fat [bleep]"
-Ooh!
[ Audience groans ]
-And here's my thing.
[ Laughter ]
I do not care for a fat-person
male making a fat woman --
calling her fat, because
this guy was fatter than me.
So I turn to him and I go,
"You're calling me fat?!"
That was my first thing.
I said, "You're calling me fat?"
And he had what I like to call,
I named it a "furtle-neck,"
which is when you're fat
and you grow a beard --
a guy grows a beard
in that fat part under here.
[ Laughter ]
And it's kind of like
nature's shading.
It's like trying to shade.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "I'm not buying it.
I can see the lobster roll
under the hair."
But so I got so crazy mad
at him,
and I was just, like, beyond.
And we weren't going anywhere.
It wasn't like, you know --
And so I just turned to him
and I went...[ Chuckles ]
"Well, guess what, buddy.
It's your lucky day because I'm
a police officer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And he's like, "You are not!"
And I go, "Spin the wheel, baby,
spin the wheel."
[ Laughter ]
And so then what I did, every
light, was create a tableau of
something I was doing that
looked police-officer-like...
[ Laughter ]
...so he would fecalize
his suit pants
and get really scared.
So every time we'd get to
another light, I'd be like...
[ Laughter ]
And I have a good kind of
dikey cop energy,
so you know it was viable.
[ Laughter ]
And every single time
we got to another light,
and I kind of started running
out of things,
so I was trying to, like, take
weird objects
and be, like, scanning, you
know, trying to, like --
[ Laughter ]
I kept looking over at his car
and trying to,
you know,
look like that, but --
-And how long ago was that?
-That was a day after
the statute of limitations
for getting in trouble
for pretending
you're a police officer.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, thank you for celebrating
the day after our anniversary.
-Yeah. Don't do that.
-Paula Pell!
Don't do that.
Paula Pell, "Girls5eva,"
streaming on Peacock.
New episodes released
on Thursday.